[MUSIC PLAYING]
CarTel is a mobile sensor
network data collection system.
The idea is we put a little
bit of hardware in cars--
this hardware consists of a
Linux box and some sensors--
and then we use this data that
we've collected from the cars
to answer sort of interesting
questions about the world.
So we synthesize data
from a bunch of cars
together in order do
things like give users
a picture of what traffic in
the city currently looks like.
We have a range of sensors
that are deployed in the cars.
All of the cars include a GPS,
a Global Positioning System,
as well as a Wi-Fi radio that
they can use for getting data
off of the cars.
Other sensors that we
put on some of the cars
include accelerometers, which
can do things like measure
the quality of the ride,
or the surface of the road
as the car drives over it,
so that, for example, you
can detect vibrations or
bumps as the car hits them.
In the CarTel project, we
have several different ways
of transmitting
data off the cars.
And one of things we've--
one of the technologies
we've been working on
is developing different
means of data transmission.
And the most basic version
of data transmission
is just to use a cell phone.
So this is somebody has
a cellular data plan,
they connect the cell
phone up to the car,
they connect a wireless data
card up to the Linux boxes
in the car, and then use that
to transmit information off.
And one of the
things that we spend
a lot of time developing
in the project
is technology to use Wi-Fi.
Part of the technology
we've developed
is to-- allows cars as they
drive by these wireless access
points to very quickly
associate with the access points
and transmit little
bits of information
every time they see one
of these access points
that's open and
available for access.
As the cars are
driving along, they're
transmitting this data off.
And what happens is
that they transmit it
to a server or a portal that's
running on a machine at MIT.
And that portal is in charge
of taking all this data
and synthesizing it
together in order
to present a sort of global
view of what's going on
in the world, or what
these sensors in cars
are observing about the world.
Typically, this data
gets put into a sort
of a visualization that gets
overlaid on top of a map.
Users can then browse
this visualization
in order to learn various
things about what's
going on inside the world.
We have a range of
different applications
that we've developed.
So the first application
is-- and the simplest one--
is just one that allows users
to browse their own driving
information.
So you may be
interested, for example,
in comparing the
amount of time that it
takes for you to drive
from home to work
on various different routes.
So you can compare
your freeway drives
to your not freeway
drives, if you
have several different routes
from your house to work
or from your work to your house.
Other applications that do
sort of more interesting things
that combine lots of
data from different cars
together include one that we
call the Pothole Patrol, which
is an application where we use
these accelerometers on the car
that are measuring the quality
of the ride to detect where
potholes are in
the city of Boston,
and then categorize them
in terms of their severity.
The third application that we
spent a lot of time developing
is a traffic portal.
So the idea here is
that we use the cars,
as they're driving along,
we can learn things
about how fast they were
able to drive on every road.
And then for each road segment,
each little piece of road,
like, for example, Mass
Ave in front of MIT,
we can compute a
distribution of the delays
that your car has experienced
when they were driving on that.
The first goal is to explore
the use of cars or mobile nodes
as sensing devices.
So how can we use
these mobile things
in order to measure the world?
And so it's about--
one goal is about
just developing
the technology that's needed to
get data off of these cars that
are moving around in the
world, and to bring it back
to a server, and to synthesize
it and store it together.
And some of the challenges
there include things
like dealing with
variable connectivity,
that the cell phones will cut
in and out as you drive around
or there isn't continuous
wireless conductivity available
everywhere.
So one goal is sort
of a technology goal.
The other goal is
an application goal,
which is to develop
some of these-- use
these cars in order to
develop applications that
are sort of new and
different, and enable
things that will help people
besides computer scientists.
This traffic portal
that I mentioned
is an example of something that
everybody could take advantage
of.
Anybody would be interested
in knowing what the best
route to take from A to B is.
Obviously, things like
MapQuest and Google Maps
have huge uptake.
And adding traffic
to those would just
increase their value.
So one of the things
that we're doing in order
to bring the cost
of this box down
is we're looking
at solutions that
include smaller amounts of
hardware inside of the car
because we think that hardware
cost is a barrier to entry.
So that, we think, will allow us
to produce a piece of hardware
that goes into the cars that
maybe only costs $30 or $40
per car, which would be
something that we think
an average person
might be willing just
to put in their car in order to
benefit from this technology.